most couples therapy is useless not
because the therapy is wrong but because
most couples don't go to therapy
together until one of them is absolutely
not wanting to work on the relationship
anymore they're using therapy as an
excuse to air their frustration one last
time
so many times I've had couples come in
and that's exactly what it is is one is
all in for it and is convinced I'm going
to fix their partner and tell them that
they've been right all along and the
other partner comes in dreading it
because their partner's the one who set
it up and they say what and what sort of
Buzz saw am I walking into and it is a
miserable experience for all three
people involved unless I can turn them
around and convince the other partner
that I'm there to help them in which
case the first partner can is convinced
that I have somehow pulled a Switcheroo
and they are now going to get betrayed
by their by their coach now who's
working with them it's an ugly process
it is really ugly the only time couples
therapy really works is when they are
coming in because they both want to make
it work but they don't have the skills
and they have no idea what to do if they
both want to make it work it's an
amazing experience if one of them
doesn't want to work and doesn't have
the guts to say it it's a horrible
experience for both people why is it so
rare for couples to go to couples
therapy before the stage that one of
them is basically ready to call it quits
and needs uh an Arbiter between the two
of them because most people do not have
the skills they need to speak to their
partner proactively and productively
about the problems so they just pretend
there aren't problems or they throw
anger and excuses at each other over and
over and over again one will try the
other withdraws then they switch and the
other tries again and the other one with
drugs and they only vent to the people
around them they don't actually go out
and get proactive solutions from the
people around them and their family
systems are usually broken so they've
never seen a healthy relationship they
think this is as good as it gets they
only seek professional help when one of
them panics because the other one has
made a change and I will also say this
women change for relationships typically
men only will change for circumstances
which is reality women will usually be
done with a relationship a year or more
before they're actually ready to get
divorced men have no idea that this is
coming men get blindsided and they say
wait I'm finally willing to give it a
try let's try couples therapy and she's
been done for a year so this is a very
common problem right there do you think
that that explains part of the reason
and that most divorces are initiated by
women absolutely at one hundred percent
because most women have spent 5 10 20
years changing for the relationship
hoping that her husband will secretly
somehow change for the relationship too
men only change when they observe a
problem and then when they believe that
there is a solvable problem there that
they can actually work on it takes both
of those things for a man to actually
work on something most men will only
change enough to try to stop the
discomfort that they're experiencing and
try to go backward
um
yeah it's uh I have a number of friends
that have either been through couples
counseling or are going to couples
counseling at the moment and I would say
that the archetype is as you've
described that it really is
if this counseling was to make the
relationship better it is a severe
uphill battle which I imagine from a
therapist's perspective makes couples
counseling
um not exactly fun
so I went through school graduate
program six years for master's degree
and then additional three years of
apprenticeship of hard apprenticeship
under clinicians so it's nine-year
process to become a marriage and family
therapist at nine years of training of
them telling us you will want to you
will get burned out on this job couple's
therapy is hard couples don't actually
usually get better very few of them do
it's hard work and you have to
completely detach from their outcomes
because otherwise you will drive
yourself crazy watching One couple after
another tear themselves apart there's
nothing you can do to help them this is
the message they gave us and it was very
true you you come in you do the best
that you can and you guide them forward
and usually the biggest piece that I
would do is this is get them to a point
where they could say what got you
together in the first place where do you
have any commonalities and where is
there even a sliver of Hope that both of
you could work together on this if
there's even a tiny shred of hope we can
make this work I well really briefly one
time I had a couple come in to my
coaching practice they both had very
very bad attachment very bad attachment
neither one of them knew it one of them
was having an affair the other one
wanted the relationship to work the one
who was having an affair wasn't sure if
they wanted it to work or not I educated
them on attachment first session
educated fully on attachment second
session got them working on bonding
together and doing what couples are
supposed to do third session taught them
communication skills and conflict
resolution by the fourth session when
they walked in
both of them were happier in their
relationship than they had ever been
even as newlyweds even as whether we're
dating the person was cheating and said
absolutely not I'm going to do this
marriage it's amazing they had healed
their attachment together and they were
now growing closer to their friends and
their family at the same time it only
took three sessions of doing the Deep
work because both of them were committed
to it if a couple wants to make it work
even extreme circumstances can work but
you must both want to make it work
how does
a pair of people who have got ingrained
responses habituated thought patterns uh
um routines built into their
communication style the way they relate
to each other the way that they show up
to each other
how can it be the case that three
sessions is all that it takes to
deprogram something which at the very
least we're taught should take 66 days
to break and make a new habit that's
absolutely true it's absolutely true
it's curious because here's the piece is
so many people are living with a
decision they made when they were one
year old that said I am scared I am hurt
I am sad I feel vulnerable people will
abandon me or people will betray me
there is something wrong with me or with
other people and I am not ever going to
be able to be open again because I will
never be this hurt that scared this
vulnerable ever again for the rest of my
life they don't even remember this
decision but that foundational belief
has been set into their brain as an
absolute fact of the universe gravity
pulls things down water is wet and love
is impossible and I must live in fear
for the rest of my life to stay safe
that foundational belief once you hear
it and say well I have been believing
that but it's probably true and someone
comes in an attachment expert comes in
and says it is not true here's an
alternate model for living that is
possible I want you to think about it
over the next week and tell me if it's
ruining your life or if this is
something that we could fix and they'll
think about it and it ruins it for them
and then they start seeing the Matrix
and they say wow maybe there is two
different ways to live and maybe I've
been living the wrong way maybe I'm
willing to learn and then they learn it
once you've got it intellectually cool
once you experience it that's where it
begins to change because when you
experience the difference your brain
chemistry balances out right we've got I
deal with the five big brain chemicals
there's more than this but the five big
ones we work we look at vasopressin
oxytocin Gaba gamma aminobiric acid and
serotonin those four are absolutely
crucial to get through your good
relationships if you don't have good
relationships you've got a dopamine
button that you can punch like a monkey
this is where people have porn addiction
and all kinds of addictions and phone
addictions and gambling addictions it's
because their brain chemistry is off
from their wounded relationships that
they've never been fulfilled it is like
a duck that is terrified of water so it
lives its whole life on land it's like a
duck who will never fly because it's
terrified of the sky as well it's a duck
who is continuously walking because it
thinks water or flying is going to kill
it that's what these people are like
as they experience even a little bit the
overwhelming brain chemistry that floods
through them from good relationships is
like a duck who finally learns to swim
or finally flies and says this is not
just not scary it is exhilarating it's
everything I was built for your brain is
built for these things and the addiction
to the good takes over and it heals you
much more rapidly than most people are
expecting it is not about habits it is
about cultivating the right experiences
so that your brain takes over for you
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]